well nobody knows where jazz is going
because nobody has ever known jazz is
going I mean you couldn't possibly
predict a swing error from the 20s or
bebop from the swing error or
avant-garde from bebop or a fusion and
on and on and on so we don't really know
where it's going but I would say this I
don't think we're going to be seeing
those kinds of distinct and discrete
movements like swing Bop infusion I
think now it's a question of individuals
now one thing is important to remember
is that in the early years of jazz a lot
of major musicians like Fletcher
Henderson and don redman had you know
college education Zand and degrees and
all of that but a lot of the great
figures like Louis Armstrong a
two-gallon did Charlie pocket did not I
mean officer didn't even go through high
school of hundreds if not thousands of
major figures learned on the bandstand
that was their apprenticeship today the
apprenticeship of musicians in the
college Orchestra I mean he's not going
to meet a musician who hasn't you know
got at least a ba and probably an MA and
hasn't been to a music school and hasn't
had giant steps as a homework assignment
so it's very different so they so
because they have this historical
perspective they aren't necessarily just
coming out of whatever their generation
is into and also because they're growing
up and they don't have the same
prejudices against pop music that
certain generations had they can use
that so you know today's musicians who
maybe grew up with hip-hop may use hip
hop beats in a way that if you're not
looking for them you won't even hear it
but it's there it's informing the way
they think of rhythm and they may use
things that they picked up from
Ellington or dizzy gillespie that isn't
particularly obvious it's not a homage
it's not a matter of playing kannamma or
a sophisticated lady it's just releasing
Zords some idea that they picked up so
all of this becomes part of the the brew
and what we're really looking for in the
future of jazz is the individual who is
saying something that expresses him or
herself that's what I look for I look
for some spa
give originality or individuality that
sets this musician apart from the pack
there were the general level of
musicianship in jazz is probably higher
now than it's ever been I can't get very
excited about a musician who can do our
tatum because I've got the art tatum
records I want to hear him take that and
do something that hasn't been done and
there's enough of that going around that
keeps the music very exciting there's so
many great young players coming out I
think we're doing some kind of
Renaissance especially in the rhythm
section I mean where the musicians on
drums and bass and guitar really trying
to figure out different ways to bring a
rhythm section together so I you know
the crossover is a constant thing one of
the things we do in the book which i
think is fairly novel I don't think
anyone's done it before but we have two
chapters on fusion instead of one
everybody when they talk about fusion
they usually are talking about the jazz
rock thing that happened in the late 60s
and 70s when Miles Davis recorded
bitches brew and you know chicka Rhea
and John McLaughlin all these guys came
along and had fusion bands using
elements of rock but we make an argument
that fusion has always been part of jazz
and that you could actually create a
sort of fusion history of jazz if you go
back even into the 30s where did Louie
Jordan the father rhythm blues come out
of the chick webb Orchestra you know
where the salsa movement come out of
machito and Muriel Bowser who played
with and Dizzy Gillespie played with all
the big bands there's always been you
know Jelly Roll Morton said you can't
make jazz without using certain elements
of Latin music so there's always been
this let me say it this way i'll quote
dexter gordon famous line he said jazz
is an octopus it will take whatever it
can use and it will work with it so I i
think the distinctions aren't as clear
as we like to think jason moran who is
the subject of the last chapter in our
book because we decided to use instead
of trying to cover the whole scene we
try we decided she's a representative
jazz musician you know at the age of 30
and she was at the time we were writing
and the two tracks we analyzed by him
one is his version of it nineteen thirty
James P Johnson stride piece called
you've got to be modernistic which he
takes completely into the realm of of
Thoroughly Modern semi avant-garde jazz
and the other is uh Afrika Bambaataa
planet rock which he does the same now
anybody knows the James P number will
recognize anybody knows the Bambaataa
number will recognize it but they will
also see that he's done something
completely different and it's not a
question of doing something clever or
cute this is what he grew up with it's
his right to use it we're going to see a
lot more of that